these rich people you know don't you get
sick and tired of all they care about is
money there's such greedy people right
you know it's crazy all this stuff I'm
telling you I grew up believing this I
literally grew up despising rich people
had certain relatives when we grew up in
Tehran Iran we were low-income families
so I've never lived in the house and
never lived in the house never I've
never lived in a house we never had a
backyard it was always an apartment and
so we come to the States parents get a
divorce I joined the army I come out and
all of a sudden I read a quote and a
book I read when it was at Bally Total
Fitness this guy recommends me this book
and the code is if you're born poor it's
not your fault but if you die poor it's
your fault by Bill Gates so wait a
minute what do you mean upon born poor
it's not my fault but if I die poor it's
my fault you're trying to say if I don't
die rich it's my fault and it's all
because of me yes why because you
control your choices your friendships
your association which you feed your
mind what you read how much TV you watch
how hard you work how much you're
improving how what industry this is all
your choices you have your choices well
Pat I live in a different country epochs
you have to you have a choice to live
through or now relate to another country
but Pat you don't understand you have
choices and when that got into my brain
I realized one thing I had a choice to
think all rich people were greedy and
bad people and you and I will never
become what we hate and I couldn't stand
rich people and I had to shift that my
limit it's not easy to do I had to shift
that mindset when I did and I realized
all these stereotypes and these myths
all of them were debunked then I started
thinking of a complete different one I'm
here to tell you my entire outcome of
this since our video is for you by the
time we're done if you don't have any
problem with rich people then this video
is going to just validate a lot of the
points that yet for yourself and even
give you more ammunition when you talk
to other people but if you're somebody
that grew up in a family that didn't
have a lot of money and you have this
intuition or you have this you know
stereotype of how rich people are I hope
by the time we're done you're going to
think about it differently now let's
start off your rich people man they're
not happy that they're so miserable you
know rich people are not happy you think
they're happy they're not happy
but here this stuff right here's what I
learn about how rich people are it's not
the fact that they're not happy they're
absolutely very happy they're not
content they are not content let me
elaborate so New England Patriots just
won the Super Bowl this past weekend and
what's the coaches in Belichick and
Edelman are being interviewed by Jimmy
Fallon and Jimmy Fallon says hey bill
when I look at you you just don't look
like you're happy he says men are you
ever happy he says I am happy it's just
life to me is football and I do football
this is probably you cancer the greatest
organization greatest coach all this
stuff says but I'm a football guy so
it's always about how can we make the
team better the offense better the
defense better the recruiting the talent
better it's always how can we make plays
better and that comes across as not
being happy but all it is is they're not
content they always want to do better
next rich people are selfish it's mine
this is mine that's mine
this is mine that is mine first of all
what is wrong with us wanting things
that are ours see back in the days in
1990 or 1989 Gorbachev from raw Russia
asks Reagan to come and visit him he
says what can I do to make our economy
be like America so he goes and says
listen regular said everybody says
everybody drives the same car everybody
has the same house everybody eats the
same food everybody wears the same color
underwear same clothes what's it's all
about so we got to give these guys an
opportunity if somebody wants to work
hard and drive a nicer car let him do it
if somebody wants to work hard to get a
big round set them do it and then they
switch to capitalism by the way fast
forward 25 26 years later today the
number one country in the world in
immigration is America with 40 something
million you know a number two is Russia
with 11 million why maybe capitalism
attracted some people to want to go out
there and live in Russia and that's it
the perfect country of course it's not
nowhere near it but it attracts because
people can finally say it's mine next
take advantage of people this actually
does happen however you can't do this
for too long you cannot do this for too
long in the world of capitalism if you
take advantage of other people other
people have the right to tell other
people about their experience with you
and if it's valid and genuine and enough
people say it then people say maybe
there is some truth to it now there's
one thing
that you have enemies and there's a lot
of people like for instance right now
the most hated person in the world today
is Donald Trump just six months ago the
most hated person in the world was
President Obama just eight years prior
to that the most hated person in the
world was George Bush just eight years
the most hated personal book
it doesn't matter whoever that gets the
biggest limelight will typically be the
most hated person but taking advantage
of people people will eventually find
that there's something going on there
you can't do that in business for too
long you got to take care of your people
if I don't take care of the best person
that's working for me he's legal me if I
don't take care of the best executive
he's legal me if I don't take you my
best partners that are trusting us with
tens of millions of dollars they're
leaving us I have to understand that I
can and if they don't treat us well I'm
leaving so there's a certain
relationship that's got to be both ways
right so this is a very very honest
formula you don't do what someone's
leaving next you know money is there god
I used to hear this all they care about
is money money is there God well first
here's what I want to do why don't we
break down what this whole meaning of
their God is it because they spend the
most time trying to get more money is
that what it is well then if that's the
case and if that's our definition of
what God means we can certainly say to
most people TVs their God we can say
Netflix is there is their God we can say
video games is their God if somebody all
they want to do is play video games we
can say porn is someone's God we can say
sex is someone's got we can say a lot of
things that someone's got so that's a
lot of things that we can see what I can
say one thing for fat hey when you do
make more money and you can do more with
the money and create more jobs with the
money then it becomes a mathematical
formula you're just finding ways to do
more with it and if you're a good person
you if you're watching this right now
let me ask you a question you think
you're a good person I'm talking to you
you you I'm talking to no no yeah I'm
talking you yeah you think you're a good
person you think you're a good person do
you think you're a good person really so
if you're a good person I got a question
for you let's just say you work very
hard and in the next five years ten
years all of a sudden you're worth 100
million dollars would you do good for
the world with that hundred million
dollars what did you just say yes okay
now can you do better for the world with
a hundred million dollars over
$200,000 maybe you said 100 million
dollars can we help you go out there and
make 100 million dollars so you can do
more good with that hundred million
dollars what's wrong with you make more
money nothing wrong with that it's a lot
better if you just sit and watch video
against the netbooks and TV and all that
other stuff or even your phone and new
students in what other people's lives
look like that's the point of money
right next everybody was a billionaire
they made their money off real estate
it's actually not true if you do but not
everybody does mix they don't give back
here's an interesting stat according to
CNBC the average ultra high-net-worth
person gives 25 million dollars back to
charities during their lifetime the
average high net worth ultra
high-net-worth person gives 25 million
dollars back to charity here's a crazy
one
the average billionaire during their
lifetime gives 100 million dollars back
to charity so this whole thing about
rich people don't give money back
believe it or not
who do you think funds most of these
charities who do you think funds most of
these nonprofits you think $5 donations
do know it's someone that comes in and
writes the big cheque is what they do
right next all they do is play golf some
of them do a lot of them do just
recently I watched a movie founder Ray
Kroc I think you got to watch it it's
insane everybody's got to watch this
movie founder and there's a scene there
where you know a Ray Kroc is trying to
close this deal with the souther guys
who buy a couple of franchises and the
guy hits the ball and he's six feet off
and it's a tall that's pretty much it's
good don't worry about it
typically it's like two feet off to say
well counted as a shot it was 670 feet
offices it's fine it's good why all he
wanted to do was just do business deal
Ray Kroc stop trying to be a
professional golfer he's trying to do
business so if a wealthy person or rich
person golf it's because they're trying
to do business some of them actually
love the game I'm not money give that up
because I've coped with certain people
that absolutely love the game but not
everybody next yachts homes all this
other stuff
yeah sure some billionaires have yachts
somebody very early and a lot of them
have private just now why did have
private just let me explain to why they
have private jets
the other day I have a business meeting
to go to in the airport the airline
takes six hours
to find a replacement then the next one
takes another four hours I get there
late to deployment I couldn't do the
business field that could have been a
good business till never happen this is
when the personal assistant says you
know what it's time to buy private jet
it's five million dollars you're going
to pay $100 100 thousand dollars a month
maybe fifty thousand dollars a month but
it's worth the investment that you're
going to make to get there faster and
get the appointments done and imagine
how many more places you can get to
without having to go through security
tsa four hours drive all this other
stuff
boom boom you're out you go and a pile
of waste and you come back quick so it's
not necessarily about the lifestyle it's
more about the time that I can get to
place much faster neck every rich person
out there is a Republican everybody if
you're rich they must be Republicans
you're Trump voters you know they love
Romney they devote their Bush their Bush
type of people you know believe it or
not a lot of millionaires are not
Republicans there's a lot of
millionaires who from California lived
in California for many years Silicon
Valley most of them are liberals they're
mostly Democrats you go into Hollywood
there's a lot of wealthy tivity there
most there's a lot of Democrats there's
a lot of liberals you go to New York a
lots of them over there both states
they're typically going to be left Trump
it in with New York you don't in
California they're liberal states and
there's a lot of millionaires on those
states now how's that even possible well
being a millionaire or a billionaire or
rich doesn't necessarily mean you have
to become a Republican they economically
believe in capitalism they don't believe
in communism they believe in capitalism
but socially they believe in other
things pro-choice they may believe in
certain things that conservatism a novel
even but just because someone's rich
doesn't make them a Republican next
they're narcissistic all they want to do
is look themselves in the mirror and
just say I'm so pretty I'm so amazing
I'm so beautiful
they're narcissistic they have problems
with how much they admire themselves one
thing I noticed is typically somebody
who lacks confidence they don't like
people with a lot of confidence even
though secretly they admired them
because like man how can somebody being
must be narcissistic not this is not
everybody I'm not putting a blanket over
everybody but what I am Telling You is
somebody who's extremely confident
doesn't necessarily mean their
narcissistic it's a strength table
I wish everybody believed in themselves
more if everybody believes in themselves
more there's going to do better in their
life
believe me half the struggle is to make
people believe that they can pull it off
in their lives as well that is half the
struggle that's what they got going on
that's a necessarily mean they're all
narcissistic are there some narcissistic
out there of course next you don't pay
their taxes they don't pay their taxes
they don't pay their taxes Paul I'm
gonna do a basic mathematical formula
here so we can actually look at it so
you can see for your sub hottest number
works
last year America the government
collected roughly three and a half
trillion dollars in federal income taxes
okay now let's set that aside for three
and a half trillion dollars today in
America there's a hundred and fifty
eight million people in total workforce
these are 158 million people that work
in America the average salary is roughly
$36,000 $36,000 158 million people
working and let's say on average they
pay 25% in taxes which is $9,000 so if
we take $9,000 multiply times the 158 we
get roughly 1.4 trillion dollars okay
that's how much the government collected
last year one point four trillion
dollars if it was only collecting the
money from people that make $37,000
$36,000 per year now watch this you take
1.4 trillion but we collect with three
and a half trillion where's the other
two point one trillion dollars where did
that come from that's because the
high-income earners who make millions of
dollars they pay a lot of taxes they pay
a lot of taxes yes there are some ways
where they figure out ways to pay less
taxes because somebody in the government
they voted for change certain laws that
they pay less taxes that's simply why it
is they can change it if they wanted to
but those loopholes are in because
somebody funded someone's campaign 10 20
30 40 years ago this is what happens
right well regardless they still pay
their taxes well pay you don't send
Trump didn't pays taxes let's just say
Trump doesn't pay taxes of course Trump
pages taxable it should say Trump
doesn't pays taxes they say does it
that's not everybody if he didn't pay so
I'm not even saying that he didn't pays
taxes the point is everyone's paying
their taxes how much they're even paying
more than a lot of people are paying and
last but not least is they party all
they do is they want to
there is extroverts are very good with
people and they just want to go out
there and they got these big
personalities all this other stuff could
it be some sure a lot of the people that
I meet who are very well-off a lot of
the people that I need to are very
well-off believe it or not they actually
kind of are the nicest people I meet
there's such nice people and they they
want to be around their kids they want
to be around their families they want to
have their vacations there's this one
man that he's also in the insurance
industry you know for 35 years look at
this year for 35 years he has one
tradition every single year for two
weeks he pays for his entire family and
he takes him on a cruise he's done it
for 35 years
think about that two weeks they go on a
cruise and the kids pick where they want
to go I said how many were that this
last one he says 35 people whereas this
last one said for 35 years and so he
says 35 people what do you pay for it
says that I pay for everything slide
room food everything they pay for
nothing he does this every year he wants
his family to be around he says to me if
I could do everything and all the time I
have so much I want to be around my
family the extravagant all that other
stuff could be a Hollywood type of a
lifestyle but it's not everybody so I
haven't said that again my pure outcome
of this video is I hear there's so many
times Pat I don't want to be rich
because rich people are greedy and all
they care about is themselves or I grew
up with this mics up that's mindset and
all this other stuff I want to talk
about this because many people have
requested on talking about this issue
and I've got a book recommendation for
you as well I've got a book
recommendation for you so Paul let's put
a picture of it up everybody can see
this is a book by T Harv Eker it's
called secrets of the millionaire mind I
highly recommend it it's exceptional
it's phenomenal everybody ought to read
it it'll make you think about
millionaires and money in a complete
different way policy at the pillow here
I was a good catch you like that catch
so one had to catch rectum phenomenal
thrown Paul you got a little bit of Tom
Brady in you yeah you got a little bit
of Brady in you
got a little bit of rating you okay all
right so here we go hey our goal is to
get two million subs by the end of the
year if you haven't subscribed click on
the button if you've already subscribe
or you don't get notifications click on
the world right next to so you get
alerted every time a new video gets up
you'll be one the first to gets it and
at a quarter million subs we're doing a
new contest to do something where people
were flying and last time we did it was
a big kid people flew him for seven
different countries we went ours over
here questioning all this others that
was phenomenal and we will do it again
out of quarter million subs I think
right now where I would 196,000 sets 197
thousand steps while recording this
video so if you haven't subscribed do
subscribe if you got any comments or
questions about today's video comment on
the bottom with that being said thanks
for watching everybody take care bye bye
[Music]